Another question we've had, and we've had it a lot,
is more information about the whole ancestor thing,
how the ancestor part of a query works, what it means, and how to work with it.
Okay, yes, I have seen that question a lot and I'll do my best to answer it.
It's Google App Engine specific--the notion of ancestor paths and ancestor queries--
but it has a couple of neat things.
The question in the forums was about ASCII Chan in particular.
We had a line that looks like this--db.key.from_path.
Then from_path can take a couple of parameters.
It can actually take, I think, as many as you want,
but in this particular example, I just used two.
It said like ASCII Chane--I'll just abbreviate it "AC"--
and then I think I had the string "arts."
So what this does is this actually creates a data store key for an object that doesn't exist.
What I basically said is all of my arts are going to have this parent,
and when I created arts--I think when I said something like a = Art,
and then you'd have all those properties--
I guess I should spell them out here. We have title.
What did I call it? Actually like the content of the art.
There are probably another parameter called "parent.
Parents equals whatever this key. We'll call that k.
I think it was a function call.
What this does is this just store the art in a database,
and it basically says its parent is this key.
The parent is supposed to be another object, but in this case the object
hasn't actually been created. It's just kind of reference to this fake object.
This is purely for organizational purposes.
There are a couple handy things you can do with this.
The first is what I was doing in ASCII Chan, which is when you're doing a query,
you can say--you have your select statement or you can be doing it procedurally.
You know how to run queries at this point.
You store this is a string and you run it. Whatever.
Select * from Arts, and then one of the constraints on this query is where ancestor
equals something.
In this case, where ancestor equals this k, this key.
What that does is it gives you this property in datastore
that the query will be consistent.
That means when you've inserted with this parent and then you immediately
do a select *, if I didn't have this where ancestor equals k,
there's a chance I might not actually get the element I just inserted,
because of the way datastore works with possibly being stored over multiple machines
and sharded and all of that.
What Google is doing there isn't entirely transparent to us,
but one of the things they say in their docs is that if you include this constraint,
ancestor equals something and that happens to be an ancestor of the object you're looking for,
the query will be consistent. That's all I was doing there.
If you look at the datastore docs, if you go to that "hello, world" example
in the datastore docs, it'll actually explain that a little bit,
and that's what I was basing this on.
Now, this came up again in the final for doing the wiki.
One of the ways that I decided to do the history is I made every page,
every path--basically URL path, like every wiki page in my program--
basically be its own path here.
I would basically just say from path, I think I called it wiki,
and then I would actually have the URL.
Then each version of the page was another object with that parent.
So when I did a wiki page--if you're just viewing the page, I would just say,
okay, get me all of the children of this parent, and I'll take the most recent one
to actually show the page, and then when you click on the history view,
I just say, give me all the children of this parent.
That's how I did the version history thing, and that actually made it really easy to do,
using datastore. This is a concept that only exists in datastore, though.
This whole parent ancestor query is where you specify the ancestor thing.
So it's actually as new to me as it is to you.
But it helps you work around a few constraints that datastore has.
I hope that helps. There is plenty of information in the Google datastore docs.
That's what I'm basing most of what I'm telling you on, anyway, so I would suggest you check that out.